[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
vaccin contre la copie 19 mieux
communiquer sur les effets indésirables
la lutte contre la pandémie de kovy
dépassé par une campagne de vaccination
massive
mais les français ont-ils toujours été
bien informés sur la sécurité de ces
vaccins développés à une vitesse inédite
en février 2022 une pétition recueillant
plus de 30 mille signatures sur le site
du sénat plaidait pour que toute la
lumière soit faite sur les effets
secondaires de ces vaccins
la commission des affaires sociales a
alors saisi l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques
le 9 juin l'opex a adopté un rapport
d'étape présenté par le député gérard le
zèle et par les sénatrices sonia de la
provôté et florence lassarade
il porte sur l'état des lieux des effets
indésirables consécutif à la vaccination
contre la copie d sur le système
français de pharmacovigilance
l'opecst sts souligner que le système de
surveillance des médicaments
piloté par l' agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament a fait preuve
d'une mobilisation remarquable et d'une
transparence inédite au cours de la
campagne vaccinale
les centres régionaux de
pharmacovigilance ont examiné un nombre
inédit de déclarations d'événements
indésirables
en complément de nombreuses études de
pharmacoépidémiologie produite par le
gia ce pays phare ont apporté des
informations sur l'efficacité et la
sécurité des vaccins par exemple sur la
survenue de myocardite en lien avec la
vaccination
ces deux approches ont permis
d'identifier rapidement les signaux de
vigilance et d'affiner en temps
quasi-réel l'estimation de la balance
bénéfices risques associés à chaque
vaccin
c'est pourquoi l'office préconise de
conforter voire de renforcer ses
dispositifs de maîtrise du risque
médicamenteux
parallèlement l'opex t'encourage une
démarche de pédagogie et de transparence
de l'ensemble des professionnels de
santé et des autorités sanitaires
condition indispensable d'une relation
de confiance avec la population
à cet égard l'office parlementaire
déplore une communication
institutionnelle insuffisante sur les
effets indésirables en comparaison de la
communication incitant à la vaccination
l'office regrette aussi que dans
certains cas des personnes touchées par
des effets indésirables consécutivement
à leur vaccination ait pu souffrir d'un
déficit de reconnaissance
les auteurs du rapport préconisent une
communication publique à la fois plus
réactive et plus pédagogique
la vérité scientifique qui n'exclut pas
les nuances et peut évoluer doit être la
référence qui guide les discours et les
décisions politiques
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]